what kind of feedback have you gotten
since you put out this list and and who
are these people how'd you come up with
them you know so first of all the
feedback has been tremendous and I think
one of the reasons is we all know the
gender diversity is a very hot topic I'm
certainly inside the tech community but
I think one of the things people are
craving right now is very tangible
solutions like you know I want to help
what can I do right the board list on
the other hand is not alyssa was curated
by me it was curated by community of
tech leaders the board list is the
sounding initiative a project that i
found a culture choose possibilities
women i presume aren't on boards right
and in Samar Samar so it's been very
interesting is I took the approach of
crowdsourcing building a tool and I went
out to 50 highly credible leaders in the
silver the Silicon Valley Community to
seed the database everyone from aaron
tveit box to fill marketo at Phil
Fernandez at Marketo to Stephanie to
Linnaeus who runs Vita and I said to
them if you were to nominate 5 10 20 30
women who you thought you would
personally endorse for a private tech
board who would it be and they all
responded overwhelmingly with I have
names for you and came together to
actually see this project called a board
list and what do you think about this
because launch X actually helps female
lead startups get resources they need
get things like funding what do you
think about what to kyndra's yeah i
think so i spent the last year at
Harvard Business School really studying
what we mean when we say there's a
gender diversity problem in tech and
what I realized sort of the bad outcome
of the research was that there isn't one
root cause that we can all rally behind
and try to fix their a lot of little
things they sort of create this perfect
storm that we're in the number that
really stood out to me that launched ex
tries to fix is that out of all the
venture capital money deployed only two
point seven percent of that goes to
female lead companies and when I sort of
dug into more of that research I
realized it's because there's this huge
information gap and women don't know how
to navigate this black box of a
fundraising process the same way that
men do you know it's interesting sue
kinder because companies are staying
private longer which means boards are
even more important right absolutely I
mean you know we often talk about gender
diversity is a public void problem I'm
not really sure why if you look at the
average length of a company's history
before it goes public it can be ten
years ago right
and from series v2 series f when you
have a company that's taking anywhere
from 20 million dollars in capital de
several hundred million of course the
idea of independent thought and
operational expertise on your board is
an unrealized opportunity yet so few
companies take advantage of it is it as
easy Anna as looking at sue Keener's
look at list and picking out a couple
candidates for you're born you know
that's me Anthony daddy yeah I know I
think to have someone of seconders
caliber and reputation be a part of this
I think is speaks volumes for where this
is gonna go in the next 10 to 15 years I
think so kinders approach is much more
top-down where women are sort of in this
position of power on the board level
what we're trying to do at launch acts
is much more bottoms up and to give
first-time female female entrepreneurs
the ability to raise money for the first
you know it's interesting because in
Europe they've mandated that's diversity
on boards do you think that we need that
here in it I'm actually i am not a fan
of quotas what I am a fan now and I
think she just hit it you know right now
gender diversity is something we need to
be attacking at all levels right how do
you create a more diverse environments
I'd your organization's how do we have
more women able to fundraise for their
companies particularly whether so many
fabulous women what companies out there
um but I think when we just step back
yeah I don't think it's about quotas I
think it's about access to talent and my
point overall earlier this week was when
we launched is how can we be the world's
leading talent economy and not be
harnessing a hundred percent of our town
how's that possible well I was happy to
see the list really really thank you so
much for raising these issues here on
the show so if